vous avez mis la photo de thibault parce
que thibault il s'est pendu à 12 ans
suite au harcèlement scolaire qui
subissaient et son entrée en sixième
thibault a vécu l'enfer
oui je sais que vous êtes très ému ce
soir vous vouliez absolument venir en
parler dans cette émission je sais que
c'est une journée très importante pour
vous je voulais que thibaut soient
présents avec nous puisque c'est lui qui
a subi toutes ces violences
ensuite nous entendent pas en des villes
issue que ça fumait
quand on a vécu avec lui cette violence
également ça nous a détruits ça nous a
c'est compliqué et s'était auto ça
représente thibault avant le collège au
co tribaux étaient heureux thibault et
eve est un petit garçon plein de vie
très curieux très intelligent avec un
esprit nous finale de justice important
c'est un petit garçon qui était très
bien intégrée qui savait prendre ses
responsabilités puisqu'il était joueur
de hand ball mais également jeunes
arbitres et à son entrée au collège
et là il est passé dans une dans un
monde de violence pour lequel je l'avais
pas forcément préparés à prier alors dès
son entrée en 6e donc thibault a vécu
comme je les dis d'enfer menaces de mort
d'aulaqi verbal alors comment ça a
commencé à savoir ça a commencé la
deuxième semaine de la rentrée scolaire
par un jeu d'humiliation il ya dix ans
bien on va te faire on va te faire un
tour de magie
donc on lui a appris c'est demain on lui
a dit à 3 tu vas voir les quelque chose
qui va se passer
effectivement il ya quelque chose qui
s'est passé on a baissé le pantalon
devant toute la récréation on lui a mis
une couleur un coup de balayette et on
l'a tapée à plusieurs reprises et
plusieurs personnes par des coups de
pied donc là j'ai été averti par le
collège puisque des camarades de classe
ont averti du coup les les
la cpe donc mon fils était complètement
abasourdi il a sauté quand même
retourner en classe l'après midi et là
un de ses anciens camarades de classe
avec qui il était en primaire lui a fait
une réflexion et pour une fois thibault
lui a répondu puisqu'il n'y avait pas
l'habitude de rétorquer à cette personne
et là ça a été le déclenchement de toute
la suite de violences d'insultés
d'injures de menaces de mort d'agression
physique en réunion parce que cette
personne n'avait pas l'habitude que
quelqu'un ose lui tenir tête lorsque
fait tabasser quotidiennement s'est fait
casser le bras alors il a été au collège
comme il était en betty parce qu'il
s'était fait une entorse par ailleurs il
y avait rien avoir du tout avec le
harcèlement il s'est fait bousculer et
là elle est tombée sur le coup d il ya
une fracture du coude donc ses camarades
petit camarade autres guy bergenti n'ont
rien trouvé mieux que c'est le bousculer
dans les escaliers parce qu'avec une
béquille et un bras dans le plâtre
c'est extrêmement facile de se mouvoir
comme ça il allait mourir dans les
escaliers on lui a retiré aussi son
attelle pour le frapper donc au lieu de
quatre semaines
de plaza a été huit semaines alors en
avril 2018 thibault donc change de
collège
on pense que ça va s'arrêter
et voilà le harcèlement reprend dans
l'autre collège et moins de 2 de preuves
mais chose qui est avéré c'est qu'à la
rentrée scolaire il a souhaité rentrer
dans un dans une association d'une carte
s'appelle louis guillot et thibaut me
disais que il se faisait passer à tabac
et qui se faisait frapper et qui
s'entendait pas avec ce groupe d'élèves
et début novembre il a décidé de quitter
le club alors vous alerter le collège et
l'éducation nationale oui de quelle
façon
alors ça c'était dans le premier collège
puisque je remarque que mon fils va
souvent à l'infirmerie s'étaient
inscrits dans pronote vous en a parlé
tout de suite de ce qu'ils subissent à
l'école ou pas du tout pas le jeu
d'humiliation oui après le fait qu'il
était menacé oui donc on est
on a essayé de joindre le professeur
principal la cpe
ensuite comme son fils devenir un peu
agressif à la maison ce qui n'avait pas
l'habitude d'être avec son petit frère
et sa petite soeur
donc je constate un changement de
comportement de la part de mon fils je
constate également que monfils se
réveille à 3 heures du matin ou des
insomnies il fait des cauchemars ilc
fils parle en dormant donc il refait
salve on est donc comprendre ce qui se
passe le sport du collège et tous ces
faisceaux m'amène chez le médecin pour
voir s'il ya quelque chose qui pourrait
l'aider à mieux dormir
à se calmer parce que je vois bien qu'il
est anxieux et que ça va pas quoi et là
il
il annonce aux médecins qu'il a déjà
qu'il a fait une tentative de suicide le
saviez pas non je ne savais pas ça m'a
complètement détruite
j'étais au bout de ma vie ce moment là
j'ai dit mais pourquoi tu as fait ça ça
va pas du tout comment tu veux que ma
mois sans remettre si tu fais ce genre
de choses c'est impossible
et en fait il s'est arrêté parce que sa
soeur est rentré dans sa chambre à ce
moment là il avait mis un oreiller pour
arrêter de respirer parce qu'il ne
pouvait plus en fait donc là le médecin
fait faire un mot au collège moi j'avais
arty surprenante l'ensemble de l'équipe
pédagogique l'ensemble des enseignantes
pour expliquer pas que du coup thibault
allait être suivi est suivi par un
psychologue qui devait plus
d'antidépresseurs parce que ça allait
vraiment pas
j'essaye d'avoir un rendez vous avec
leur proviseur du collège à plusieurs
reprises j'ai demandé à la cpi d'avoir
un rendez-vous avec le proviseur du
collège a jamais été fait avec le
professeur principal n'a jamais été fait
et j'ai obtenu un coup de téléphone
après avoir envoyé un courrier en
recommandé à la proviseure pour avoir un
rendez vous avec copier un inspection
académique
alors ensuite il ya la nuit du 20 au 21
novembre
alors je sais que c'est compliqué pour
vous de la raconter
alors pour extraire mon fils de cet
environnement de violence puisque les
agresseur habitait dans la ville et
n'osaient plus sortir de la maison
on allait changer de collège mais ça
changeait pas son état d'angoissé
j'ai réussi à avoir une mutation à plus
de 500 kilomètres donc quand ça s'est
passé moi j'étais à plus de 500
kilomètres de la maison j'étais parti
courir et je vois que mon mari m'a
appelé et là j'entends un hurlement mais
un hurlement
je comprends même pas ce qu'il dit en
fait donc je le rappelle est fait
thibault s'est pendu thibault s'est
pendu arrête c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible
et là j'ai je peux pas y croire c'est
pas possible j'appelle ma mère chez main
va vite je comprends pas j'appelle ma
belle-mère abbazi dépêche-toi thibault
il a un problème il faut aller le sauver
c'est pas possible
et là je m'assois sur les marches des
escaliers et je hurle mais je hurle je
n'aime pas qu'on dirait je sais pas si
c'est pas possible tu peux c'est pas
possible
thibault il n'a pas pu faire ça thibault
il a pu n'ai pas pu faire ça il n'a pas
vécu
non vraiment pas jusqu'au moment où mais
j'arrive à la maison je monte les
escaliers
là les pompiers avaient à langer
thibault sur le lit et là je vous la
porte et je la referme automatiquement
parce que c'est une vision c'est une
vision d'horreur c'est eva comprend
savez votre petit garçon qui est là
allongé la tête complètement déformés
c'est une vision d'horreur
et là vous rouvrez la porte et vous dit
pas si c'est la réalité et la seule
chose que vous voyez c'est la fenêtre
vous avez juste envie c'est de sauter
par la fenêtre c'est sylvie dit je peux
pas rester là je peux pas rester là
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible
et voyez votre mari vous avez même plus
envie de rester là vous avez juste envie
de sauter par la fenêtre et que ça
s'arrête la douleur la douleur le trou
le puissance et là on vous dit qu'il
faut dire au revoir à votre fils et là
vous lui caresser les cheveux pleurer
vous n'êtes pas bien là votre main votre
main touche son coup et là vous sentez
je sa presse et un trou noir je suis
tombé dans les pommes très fort
témoignage de karine théorique on a du
mal à voile à amiens vous questionnez là
dessus parce que c'est c'est incroyable
on a l'impression de vivre la scène avec
vous je vous crois qu'il ya c'est celle
et les grands parents de mes parents qui
sont extrêmement émus également la
question qu'on a envie de vous poser
c'est aujourd'hui est-ce que vous en
voulez quelqu'un ce que vous pensez vous
auriez pu éviter ça si vous avez eu un
rendez-vous peut-être plus tôt avec
l'établissement avec les personnes de
l'éducation nationale est-ce que vous
pensez que ça aurait peut être évité ce
drame si elle a jamais été entendu nous
n'avons jamais été entendu par
l'éducation nationale savons pas n'a pas
été entendu puisqu'on n'a pas été reçue
on n'a pas été entendu puisque quand on
vous allez voir le chef d'établissement
il vous explique que c'est votre enfant
qui est dysfonctionnements qu'il ya un
dysfonctionnement que si votre fils il
se fait taper c'est parce qu'il insulte
comme s'il y avait une excuse à se faire
taper si mon fils il insultait c'est
juste qu'il a adopté les codes qu'il
avait en face de lui parce qu'à la
maison il insulté personne dont on dit
l'insulté personnelle était très
intégrée oui l'éducation nationale pour
moi a failli là l'équipe pédagogique
était au courant elle à la liste des des
faits elle a des les noms des personnes
il n'y a jamais rien qui a été fait mon
fils me disait toute façon on vient me
voir en me basant hiva le dira cpe tout
à santa fe on n'est pas puni adrien
taquet quand vous entendez ce témoignage
de karine ce quelle réponse vous pouvez
lui donner parce que tous ici on le voit
bien on est atterré par ce qui s'est
passé de la terre est qui et qui rien
qui peut être fait qu'elle ait pas
réussi à avoir un rendez vous et c'est
pas la première fois qu'on entend ce
genre de témoignage à chaque fois
c'est les mêmes témoignages qui revient
donc on peut dire une fois ya pu avoir
un dysfonctionnement deux fois mais les
témoignages
à chaque fois nous racontent la même
chose qu'à pas de rendez vous qui a pas
de suivi cas pas de sanction qui a pas
de convocation des parents qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
parce que là on le voit ce qu'a vécu
karine ses skis et karine hélas je crois
ce soir au c'est pour ça c'est qu'elle
veut pas que ça arrive à d'autres
parents à d'autres enfants et
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que ya
dysfonctionnement sais c'est dur
s'exprimer suite à votre votre
témoignage et perdre un enfant c'est
juste de l'ordre de l'impensable
et là c'est pas le ministre qui vous
parle c'est le sait le père que j'ai
deux jeunes enfants
moi aussi et c'est difficile de ne pas
se projeter quand même dans ce que vous
dites moi je vais revenir sur les
gouvernements prévoient sur le plan qu'a
annoncé jean michel blanquer with us
dernier mais avant ça parce que je pense
que ça soulève votre témoignage soulève
un peu ce cet aspect là je pense que que
dans notre pays et c'est pas que sur la
question du harcèlement scolaire c'est
sur la question des violences faites aux
enfants globalement notre pays on a un
prêt avec la parole des enfants
on a du mal à écouter les enfants
à les entendre on a du mal à les croire
ça remonte à loin c'est peut-être
alimenté par des affaires judiciaires
12 - récentes qui ont ont pas le vrai
dans le bon sens je pense à outreau sur
prêts vous savez la halle à la racine du
mot enfant l'étymologie c'est une femme
thème en latin ça veut dire celui qui ne
parle pas celui qui ne parle pas c'est
aussi peut-être lui que l'on écoute pas
et je pense que sur les violences faites
aux enfants et nos agents sur le
harcèlement scolaire
je pense que sur le harcèlement scolaire
on est en train collectivement de passer
une étape importante nécessaire mais pas
suffisante qui est de sortir du déni je
pense qu'on sort du déni face à ce
phénomène larmes et des émissions comme
celle où nous partageons ce soir il y
contribue et je vous remercie à cet
égard mais maintenant il faut qu'on
brise la loi du silence faut qu'on brise
le silence
il faut permettre aux enfants harcelés
de parler il faut leur expliquer qu'il
faut sortir du silence que le silence en
ferme que le silence parfois dans lequel
on s'enferme on a l'impression que ça
nous protègent contre cette mort sociale
qui fait qu'on va être exclu du groupe
on a peur des représailles mais qui en
fait est une et on est on le voit
dramatiquement et est souvent une mort à
petit feu
en réalité il faut que les gens autour
des enfants harcelés par l'oci et c'est
tout le sens de ya une campagne de
communication con que le ministre
blanquet relance aujourd'hui
alors justement rien d'une euros versée
à 1,3020 on va y revenir mais cliquer
sur la nécessité de pour les gens qui
sont autour de de parler pour les
copains qui regardent d'intervenir et je
suis pas si vous avez vu mais il ya le
président de la république l'a qui a
publié quelque chose sur le snap
chaptelat récemment parce que snapshots
et aussi là où sont les enfants et en
disant mais quand on reste silencieux
face à des situations comme ça quand on
est complice lan plus rien de moins et
il faut briser ce silence mais moi ward
longtemps ceux des pères adrien quand
vous dites est amochée jeu large mais je
vais aller loin mais quand on ne donne
pas au rendez-vous à sale arabe quand
l'établissement scolaire
quand l'éducation nationale ne fait rien
pour moi on est aussi qu'il est résigné
à libérer la parole c'est bien oui mais
il faut savoir la recueillir il faut la
recueillir
il faut l'écouter alors c'est dans son
et agir et agir
oui mais ça commence c'est déjà une des
collections de d'écouter et d'entendre
ces c'est un peu tout le sens des
mesures qui ont été annoncées notamment
en mai dernier mais qui remonte c'est la
prise en compte du harcèlement scolaire
ça remonte à 2011 simplement les
premiers plans le numéro le 30 juin vous
évoquez ça à quelques années c'est pour
ça que je sais qu'on sort à peine du
déni mais aujourd'hui ce que le ministre
blanc caire a annoncé c'est
effectivement la fourniture à l'ensemble
la sensibilisation la formation de
l'ensemble des professionnels de
l'éducation nationale de l'ensemble des
directeurs leurs maîtres en main un
programme clé en main justement pour
lutter prévenir et lutter contre le
harcèlement s'est formé l'ensemble des
professeurs les directeurs
d'établissement c'est une
sensibilisation de 10 heures par an pour
les élèves c'est la création d'un petit
pédagogiques pour les étudiants mais
aussi pour les élèves ambassadeurs parce
qu'il ya tout un système aujourd'hui
dans les écoles dans les collèges
vous avez plus de dix mille enfants
ambassadeurs qui sont là pour voir
comment ça se passe entre les élèves
pour recueillir la parole éventuellement
d'un enfant qui est harcelé parce que
parce que parler de pair à pair c'est
souvent important écart a je crois que
vous êtes ambassadeur dans votre dans
votre école c'est une sensibilisation
des parents aussi parce que les parents
de harceleur brigitte macron l'a dit
tout à l'heure nous étions dans un
collège avec avec le jean michel
blanquer origines macron parfois être
parent d'un petit caïd bas c'est plus
facile que d'être parent d'un enfant
harceler donc les parents aussi ont une
responsabilité
je veux dire par là c'est que
gouvernement prend des mesures on a
élargit aussi les les plages horaires du
30 20 du 0 800 200 milles qui est la
plateforme des coudes pour le cyber
harcèlement et j'espère qu'on reviendra
sur la question du barça ont parfois
relais mais ça repose aussi sur chacun
d'eux la question des violences faites
aux enfants
on est dans une situation telle dans
notre pays aujourd'hui la réponse le
gouvernement assume ses relations à ses
responsabilités prendra des mesures mais
je vous assure que la réponse ne
pourrait être que collectivement moi je
vais vous dire la vérité ce que je
ressens adrien taquet c'est qu'il n'y a
pas assez de sanctions je suis désolé
que les harceleurs soit pas soit pas et
j'en passe au dessus a dit que les
parents n'est même pas été convoqué il
vous le rendra là dessus sinon ça c'est
incroyable
mais aujourd'hui j'ai à la
sensibilisation et l et l'engagement de
l'éducation nationale toute entière de
son ministre évidemment de brigitte
macron ça a été évoqué du président de
la république
aujourd'hui je
je ne pourrais je ne peux pas concevoir
qu'un chef d'établissement aujourd'hui
qu'un concert d un conseiller
d'éducation c'est puisse aujourd'hui est
resté silencieux face à une situation
qui se reproduiraient comme celle ci dit
tout dans ma vie c'est ce que cela se
reproduit parce que je suis encore
contacté par des parents ou alors sont
dans le même établissement qui vivent la
même chose que ce que j'ai vécu
on leur dit que leurs enfants sont 10
fonctionnant que aujourd'hui qu'on
préfère que ce soit l'enfant qu'ils
soient reçus les qui changent
d'établissement parce qu'on va pas
changer d'établissement d'une quinzaine
d'autres en six ans mais ses 50 ans et
nos enfants qui sont victimes qui
doivent se déplacer dans un autre
établissement c'est nous en tant que
parents qui devront s'organiser toujours
tablissements sont plus loin et donc du
coup ils sont obligés de rester plus
longtemps dans les établissements
également ils sont déracinés de leur ami
qu'ils ont connue depuis l'enfance celle
du ccc injuste dans tous les
c'est pas un témoignage isolé puisque à
chaque fois qu'on a évoqué le sujet à
chaque fois on a les mêmes témoignages
que vous karine donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est assez aux cordes rui
laurence ça y est moi j'ai deux trois
questions à vous poser mais je vais être
parce que tout le monde en a beaucoup
j'imagine
est-ce que vous êtes prêts aujourd'hui
on nous traite votre bonne volonté de
tout ce que vous voulez en place à
prendre l'engagement ferme que plus
jamais on ne fasse se changer d'école un
enfant alors que c'est lui la victime
déjà
est ce que vous êtes prêt à vous engager
à sanctionner les chefs d'établissement
il ne prendrait pas en compte la parole
des parents et des victimes
et enfin troisième chose vous savez le
harcèlement c'est beaucoup en école
primaire
d'ailleurs c'est le pourcentage le plus
élevé et 12% est ce que vous que le fait
qu'un enseignant à l'école primaire
collège faire place aux 10% légaux sous
les mers et 10% au collège ce sport son
pied ces bons chiffres
je crois le 3 laurent se disent qu'après
douze et dix croient que c'est le
collège maintenant tu es sage mais met
plein les chiffres aujourd'hui c'est ce
que la relève à peu importe importe mais
est ce que vous pensez
moi j'ai deux observations déjà ce que
vous pensez qu'un enfant primaire peut
faire le 30 20 je ne pense pas et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut à mon avis trouver
d'autres solutions pour permettre de
libérer la parole de manière anonyme
pour les enfants et enfin en terme de
communication vous parlez de
sensibilisation il ya une campagne
sensibiliser
surnom harcèlement mais qui passe mais
qui est totalement incompréhensible pour
les enfants entre deux dessins animés
comme vous avez je sais pas pour ceux
qui ont des enfants si vous regardez les
dessins animés avec eux quand vous avez
une personne qui arrive et qui dit non
harcèlement et le message soit si vous
n'avez pas un adulte à côté pour
expliquer ce qu'elle harcèlement ça ne
fonctionne pas donc vous avez de la
bonne volonté mais il ya plein de choses
qui sont il me semble en décalage avec
la réalité de terrain et j'ai le
sentiment dans ce que j'ai pu lire que
les associations de parents que ce que
vous mettez en place ont le sentiment de
ne pas être entendus et pas être compris
suffisamment aujourd'hui écouter ce
qu'on met en place et mis en place
depuis la rentrée
depuis septembre de cette année c'est le
plan gelée indique a été a été dévoilée
en mai dernier donc ne tirez pas de
conclusions hâtives et moi deux choses
d'une part ya pas de fatalité face à 100
les pays comme la norvège ont divisé par
deux le nombre de cas de harcèlement et
un certain nombre de choses que nous
mettons en place notamment ce programme
que nous que nous mettons à disposition
des établissements un peu un peu clé en
main parce que les professeurs de
l'éducation nationale sont assez
dépourvus face à ces à ces sujets là et
notamment face à la question du
cyberharcèlement une fois encore la
norvège on s'inspire de ce qu'a fait la
norvège qui a divisé par un parent de la
possible les cas de harcèlement la même
façon oui ce sont 700 mille sept cent
mille euros en fonction de ce qui est
phénoménal c'est 10,2 pour cent des
élèves ont là les derniers résultats que
nous avons montrent qu'il ya une
tendance plutôt à la baisse mais c'est
encore trop élevé gagne 1% et c'est
encore le chemin est encore très long ce
que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il ya
pas de fatalité
il n'y a pas de réponse unique vous nous
demandez à moi accessoirement ne suis
pas misé l'éducation nationale de
m'engager sur des mesures uniques et
exclusives
alors que face à ça vous avez 700000
situation différente personnel donc
patienter soit proche le bar compte
réaliser
évidemment c'est là c'est la double
peine et vous le savez il ya un sujet
qui est dans l'actualité assez fort
heureusement qui est celui des violences
conjugales et ce même genre de bordeaux
où la femme qui est victime de violence
est elle qui doit partir souvent avec
son enfant d'ailleurs qui
alors que déjà victimes des violences
dans le couple doit aussi quitter on a
le même genre de phénomène et on a donc
le même genre de réflexion quant à la
campagne de communication que vous
évoquez je sais pas laquelle vous
évoquez le sionisme qui est sorti
aujourd'hui kyi qui a été réalisé par
des enfants en réalité et ses fonctions
en fonction de ce qu'ils allaient donc
pas laisser passer ça s'est passé là bon
ben voilà bah valve à l'arrêt serait que
dès que vous verrez la nouvelle ces sont
des enfants qui l'ont écrit à partir de
ce qu'ils ont vécu et ça met en scène
cette dynamique collective qui est
importante c'est à dire à un moment
ensemble
eh ben on est plus forts contre le
contre le harcèlement et il faut qu' il
faut que l' isolement il faut que le il
faut que la honte change de camp c'est
ça n'est pas du côté des affres de
arsenal doit être durs cela elle doit du
côté du du harceleur cessé d'être
harceleur qui est ringard et et qui doit
être stigmatisés non juste vous dire moi
je regardais les dix mesures qui ont été
annoncées
présenté par le ministre de l'éducation
je ne vois aucune de ces mesures qui
auraient pu sauver cet enfant
aucune de ces mesures pardon ce que vous
pouvez sont elles sont théoriques jouer
nous et je les hais les bains l'a par
exemple ou trois noms mais trois
inscrire dans le code de l'éducation aux
droits des enfants à ceux qui veulent
arrêter sans harcèlement bennes ont
proposé un programme anti harcèlement
clés en main aux écoles et au collège
mais ça c'est tout satisfaire garder le
bétail niakaté rigueur je vais vous dire
sion qui est un homme et je vous dis
sincèrement gérable à la formation la
réserve est il anormal sociale seule
chose qui est tellement intéressant
c'est sûr toutes les mesures instituées
dès le cp un prix non au harcèlement et
lancé une campagne de communication pour
les élèves du premier degré quant à
pardon mais je veux dire excusez moi ça
manque de concret ça ça pardonnez moi je
vous dis moi non mais je vais pour
gagner point donc pour moi je trouve ça
très théorique je regardais j'ai rien
compris c'est trop serré et la deuxième
chose il ya aussi un angle qu'on ne
connaît pas du tout utilisé c'est la
punition c'est à dire la sociaux c'est à
la sanction
personne ne sait qu'un enfant mineur qui
harcèlent
il encourt une peine de six mois de
prison et 7500 euros damende majeurs 1
en prison
et 15000 euros d'amendé ça aussi il faut
communiquer là dessus c'est ce que ces
assemblées de remarques
qu'est ce que cela implique et déjà
c'est alors non mais c'est 50 en valais
alors les jeunes vous je suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le fait que ça
soit théorique vous dites inscrire le
droit à une éducation son harcèlement
dans le code de l'éducation il dit que
c'est théorique ça peut paraître
symbolique suis pas d'accord avec ça ça
permet d'une part c'est une base légale
pour l'ensemble des établissements pour
créer pour mettre sur pied des plans de
prévention du harcèlement
c'est aussi grâce à ça que par exemple
on va pouvoir aller voir les plateformes
internet les réseaux sociaux sur lequel
le cyber seulement cyberharcèlement a
lieu et qu'on va pouvoir leur dire vous
voyez est une base légale vous devez
retirer les contenus qui concourent au
cyber harcèlement des des élèves
le plan de le plan que vous évoquez le
programme vous dites c'est flou non ce
qu'il ya dedans c'est 10 heures de
sensibilisation par élèves par an pour
les élèves afin de les sensibiliser à
ces questions là leur dire quels sont
les risques leur dire éventuellement
quels sont les risques encourus
parce que oui a déjà des choses qui
existent vous avez raison de la sanction
ça existe les sanctions existent déjà
effectivement bas il faut peut-être le
redire justement cette connaît mais
cette sensibilisation à zéro dès 10h
sert à st ils ont pas été assez bons
plans de formation je remercie
d'ailleurs pas être appliqué dans le cas
de madame alors elles n'ont pas été
appliquées mais elle elle existe une
fois encore l'ensemble des
professionnels de l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui sont sensibilisés à sa
question à ces questions là et est on ne
peut plus admettre qu'une situation
comme celle que que vous avez vécu que
votre fils a vécu puisse puisse se
réaliser mais une fois encore ces
mesures sont au contraire concrètes il
ya de la formation il ya la mise à
disposition d'outils tout près pour les
personnels d'éducation nationale pour
les parents pour les élèves ambassadeurs
il y à face à des cas très complexe face
à des cas très complexe il ya des
références dans chaque académie qui ont
été mis en place ya 350 référent
harcèlement scolaire aujourd'hui en
france quand vous avez un cas complexe
dans un dans un établissement
vous pouvez le chef d'établissement peut
faire intervenir une équipe extérieure
pour avoir un regard tiers avec un
pédagogue avec un psychologue avec un
médecin assistant social cissé
si c'est nécessaire pour traiter séka
séka complexe donc au contraire je suis
très très concret à la première je suis
effaré par les chiffres que vous avez
dans les séries parmi dix mille enfants
n'étaient pas du tout et dix mille
enfants parents qui moi ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est comme être pas plus
de moyens dans l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui moi j'ai des j'ai deux
nièces qui sont professeurs des écoles
j'attrape de gamin tu peux pas occuper
les 30 années maintenant il est édité et
échappent bien sûr et pourquoi on fait
pas déconner ddd des classes à 15 déjà
pourquoi mais pas plus de moyens plutôt
profession etc
c'est la base d'abord pour bien
d'apprendre à l'école ça ferait des
choses on sait très bien qu'on est on
est classé d'aller dans les plus mauvais
au niveau donné au niveau des écoles
vous avez fait on n'est pas dans les
meilleures photos - et en plus des
relations récentes et en plus je je je
je je le répète elle me disait ma nièce
rien on ne peut pas on ne peut pas gérer
trappe des gamins on s'était dit
qu'aujourd'hui l'école elle n'est pas
reconnue
moi je me rappelle très très bien mon
instituteur à l'époque s'appelait
l'instituteur tu peux te garantir
on était une quinzaine dans la classe
taipan bizarre ce n'est quelques uns ça
c'est clair parce qu'il était dur
c'était et l instituteur il faut que ce
soit il faut que ça redevienne le patron
l'instituteur 5 x 5 x c'est quoi
aujourd'hui c'est pas les instituts
commencer les enfants qui commande
alors il faut remettre des moyennes de
l'éducation nationale